asian migrant guadalupe
shows us the shack where she and her
family have been living for two weeks
since arriving in this colombian beach
town
there is no running water look this is
what we have for 12 people all crammed
here spending eight dollars a day
we have kids who need to eat prices of
food have doubled since we arrived and
we had no plans to stay here for weeks
she's one of nearly 22 000 haitians
mostly arriving from brazil in chile who
are holed up waiting to catch a boat
toward the dangerous jungle of the
durian gap to continue their journey
north but panama is allowing only 500
migrants to enter each day
a human bottleneck that has brought the
town's infrastructure to a breaking
point but has also revitalized an
economy devastated by covid 19 mostly to
detriment of the migrants
haitians are paying premium prices for
food and other basic items often being
forced to pay in dollars
a cottage industry has grown to respond
to their needs
stalls like this one have appeared all
over town selling everything the
migrants need to cross the jungle from
sleeping mats to boots
raincoats headlights portable kitchens
and even special bombs that people hear
say protect you from poisonous snakes
over a hundred families have been
expelled from their apartments by
landlords hoping to make quick cash like
mechanic victor lopez who has lost his
house and workshop and is now working on
the street and living with his daughter
they kicked me out to make space for the
haitians from one day to another and
gave me no time to find an alternative
ismail guevara is hosting up to 30
migrants per day in his home which he is
now expanding he rejects accusations
that is taking advantage of people's
despair saying he's providing a service
it's a mix of opportunities and needs
they need a safe place to stay
with their women and children a roof a
kitchen where they can cook and we open
the doors of our homes yes we earn money
but not everyone opens its doors to
migrants
fearing she'll end up having to pitch a
tent on the beach guadalupe spends every
day hoping to change her boat tickets
scheduled for october 18th to an earlier
date
but she says it's all worth it to offer
her family a better future
all i want is to reach a place where i
can live safely and freely where my
children can study and make a life for
themselves
colombian officials believe that
president biden's efforts to deport
haitians from the u.s will halt the flow
of migrants through nekkoclei but for
now their numbers keep growing
alessandra
al jazeera